on this thursday night another giant
leap nasa's rover survives a harrowing
descent and lands on mars
what it's searching for and what it's
paving the way for
varying vaccine rollouts we just need
the vaccines
we don't have vaccines a patchwork of
plans and priorities
the government's broken promises on
clean water are we supposed to live like
this our whole lives
frustration on first nations over a
decades-long crisis
and unfriended facebook's face off with
australia
what's canada's plan to make tech giants
pay for news content
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us a
new era of exploration on mars has begun
nasa's perseverance rover landed on the
red planet today after a nail-biting
descent
touchdown confirmed
[Applause]
relief and exhilaration at mission
control after a 482 million kilometer
journey
and at the moment of touchdown this
tweet i'm safe on mars
perseverance will get you anywhere
within minutes the first images of the
landing site were beamed back to earth
those images are just the start of an
epic quest to not only search for signs
of ancient life on mars but to send
samples of the planet back to earth
there have been other missions to mars
but
none as sophisticated as this eric
sorensen has our top story tonight
we have confirmation of entry interface
a journey of seven months came down to
holding your breath for seven minutes
as perseverance plunged through the
martian atmosphere at thousands of
kilometers an hour
slowed by a parachute and finally
rockets to ease the one-ton rover to the
surface
the team on earth could only wait for a
signal
confirmed
[Applause]
this is just an incredible mission
because of the science and the
technology
what an amazing team um to work through
all the adversity that goes and all the
challenges that go with landing a rover
on mars
perseverance landed at jezreel crater
why here
because it was once a lake fed by a
river that created a delta where
deposits were once laid
deposits that some four billion years
later should still be there
deltas are great at preserving organic
matter and other types of biosignatures
bio signatures means signs of life
primitive life
but very real we are not looking for
advanced life forms we are looking
by analogy to what we find in the
similar time on earth
microbial life perseverance will snoop
around for years
a canadian part of the team telling it
what to do the rover picks up those
commands
executes them takes pictures does
analyses and i'm going to help with
using the instrument to analyze the
composition of rocks and soils and help
to interpret some of the data
the rover will examine rocks and will
drill several samples to be sealed and
brought back to earth in 10 years by
future missions
for scientists like canadian chris hurd
to study we'll be able to hopefully tell
that a particular rock that we
investigate with the rover
could have you know organic matter in it
but it's not until we get a sample that
back to labs on the earth that we'd be
able to say
for sure that life was actually there if
there was life on mars
it tells us that maybe the conditions to
create life are not necessarily all that
unique
i feel like that's so important for
putting humans in the context of the
universe
we want to know if we're alone one other
aim of the mission to test
new technologies for a different life
form on mars
in about 15 years when humans plan to
visit
the red planet eric sorensen global news
toronto in keeping with a tradition that
dates back to the early space age
perseverance has brought a few goodies
to mars one is the
ingenuity helicopter the first ever to
fly on another planet perseverance is
also carrying the names of 10.9 million
people
etched onto three small silicon chips
and there's a special shout out to
healthcare workers a
commemorative plate symbolizing healing
and medicine to honor those on the front
lines of the pandemic and on the front
lines here in canada the spread of
covid19 appears to be slowing down but
that could change quickly as more
contagious new variants gain ground
40 more variant cases were confirmed in
ontario today there are now 359
confirmed cases in that province
most are the b117 variant first
identified
in the uk the ontario government says
it's still deciding whether to delay
easing restrictions in parts of the
province
the top public health doctors in toronto
and peel region have asked the province
to
keep the stay-at-home order in place
until at least march 9th to help slow
the spread of the variants
new brunswick is changing its vaccine
rollout plan to try to counter the
threat from the new variants
the province's top doctor says in some
cases the second dose will be delayed up
to 90 days
so healthcare teams can get the first
dose to as many people
as possible we find ourselves in the eye
of a perfect storm that could lead to
new outbreaks
we really have to make sure that our
citizens in new brunswick that are the
most at risk
receive protection against the virus
canada's public health agency says today
vaccine deliveries are back on track and
it is optimistic canada will hit and
even exceed its previous target
according to a new federal forecast
there should be enough moderna and
pfizer biotech doses to fully vaccinate
14.5 million canadians by the end of
june
the previous estimate was 13 million
people and
up to 24.5 million canadians could be
immunized
by june if other vaccines are approved
for use
many of the premiers have complained
about the slow vaccine delivery
as supply ramps up the pressure is on
them to have a vaccine
strategy that is ready to roll as
abigail beeman reports
some provinces are better prepared than
others
our province is ready for mass vaccine
rollout it's a different picture right
across the country
newfoundland and alberta have released
zero details i frankly don't understand
the huge rush because
we haven't even really gotten into phase
1b yet we don't have enough vaccines new
brunswick and quebec detail who will be
in the next priority groups but don't
offer much
more i'm very anxious and in the next
few weeks i will try to start visiting
the places where we'll
have mass vaccination we're trying to
hire people and they look kind of
desperate
to to get those resources right now so
i'm a little bit worried
nova scotia and prince edward island are
planning community vaccination clinics
in march but haven't said anything
about april or beyond ontario aims to
vaccinate
a hundred and fifty thousand people a
day at mass vaccination sites in the
spring
public health units and public health
physicians are developing plans
on how to enact the larger plan at a
local level
manitoba's goal twenty thousand a day by
april first
saskatchewan is ramping up staff for 230
clinics
we do have the capacity we just need the
vaccines but warren's phase
two start could be delayed as late as
june and bc
is planning for 172 clinics in phase
three we've got good people in place
we're ready to go
we don't have vaccines while many
provinces talk about centralized booking
systems online and by phone
most are prepping for a march launch i
have not seen too many plans that are
very concrete
and detailed logistics expert mahesh
nagarajan says there's much
to plan facilities people information
systems monitoring for things like
allergic reactions
the nature of covid19 makes it all more
complicated
we need to be looking at social
distancing so it was not like the flu
vaccine where we could line up easily
using pharmacists does seem to be a
countrywide plan
we think that you know we can
comfortably administer at least at a
bare minimum of a million uh
you know covered shots a week and
probably closer to two to three million
but like millions of canadians they're
still waiting for specifics
too abigail beeman global news ottawa
the federal government has tabled
legislation to reform canada's justice
system the bill would repeal mandatory
minimum penalties giving judges more
leeway when sentencing for minor drug
and gun
related offenses these penalties have
been shown
to contribute to the over-incarceration
of indigenous people
of black people and of marginalized
canadians
we are simply restoring the judge's
ability to impose the sentence that fits
the crime if passed the legislation
would also allow for greater use of
conditional sentences such as house
arrest and addiction treatment for
people who do not pose a threat to the
public
mandatory minimum penalties would remain
in place for serious crimes
the federal government promised to
eliminate all boil water advisories on
first nations in this country by next
month
dozens of communities do not have safe
access to clean drinking water
a joint investigation by global news
aptn and the institute for investigative
journalism has uncovered allegations
the government's own procurement
policies may be part of the problem
christa hesse explains it's a detriment
to health and a dehumanizing problem
faced by many first nations across the
country
lack of access to safe drinking water
charla muniz is 23 years old and has
never had access to clean drinking water
at home sometimes like i just feel like
losing hope
like what's the point like are we
supposed to live like this our whole
lives is that what they expect of us
the trudeau government has pledged
nearly two billion dollars and made
promises to solve the water crisis
so why is this still happening a
year-long joint investigation by global
news
aptn news and the institute for
investigative journalism
has uncovered allegations that systemic
issues with indigenous services canada's
policies
and a lack of oversight are a
significant part of the problem
first nations leaders and industry
experts allege federal policies that
require first nations to work with the
lowest bidders on infrastructure
contracts
has led to communities receiving shoddy
work there's always
issues with the the bidding system
rather than putting quality management
first
its lowest cost a spokesperson for
indigenous services canada said in a
statement
that the low bid policy follows industry
standards
and there's another problem indigenous
services canada does not keep track of
contractors who have done poor quality
work
meaning there's nothing to alert first
nations before awarding another contract
to a company with past issues
it doesn't matter how many billions and
millions they spend
on indigenous projects
the underlying model remains uh
broken and they don't seem to want to
fix it we took these concerns to
indigenous services canada minister mark
miller
and asked him if he would commit to
tracking complaints about contractors
going forward
i'm keen to have as much data as
possible
and if it's helpful in ensuring that
the people don't aren't the subject of
sharp practices minister miller has also
agreed to investigate the business
practices of contractors
working in northern ontario communities
but as more promises are made
first nations communities continue to
wait for basic human rights
some now for decades why
what does that say about our country
christa hessie global news
on the new reality we take a deeper look
at how outdated federal policies have
allowed poor quality
infrastructure work to persist you can
watch that this saturday here on global
while texas freezes the state senator
flies off to mexico
why the power crisis was a disaster
waiting to happen
the extreme cold in texas is a lesson to
the rest of the world
climate change will make extreme cold
and extreme heat events more common
texas clearly was not prepared for
extreme cold
the collapse of its power grid has
caused a cascade of problems
affecting heat water food and medicine
and as jackson proskow reports it didn't
have to be this way
after days without heat texans are
coming home to heartbreak
our whole apartment burst pipes water
still undrinkable there's no dairy no
frozen vegetables
while grocery stores run dry pretty
short on supplies especially water
right now the search for warmth has led
to tragedy
hundreds of cases of carbon monoxide
poisoning
and fires this one killed three children
and their grandmother
for this natural disaster officials are
facing blame
for failing to protect the power grid
from a situation just like this
the warnings have been there for years
and
governor abbott has done nothing before
that governor perry did nothing
this was a train wreck on the way to
happening
10 years ago in 2011 another winter
storm prompted urgent pleas from federal
regulators for texas to winterize its
vulnerable power plants
to keep them from failing it didn't
happen
in part because texas operates on its
own power grid
unconnected to the rest of the u.s and
out of reach of federal regulations
every source of power that the state of
texas has
has been compromised the decision kept
electricity prices low
but has exacted an unimaginable cost the
state's electric grid came within
minutes of total collapse
that could have cut power for months i
don't want to raise false hope
and pretend that things are gonna get
meaningfully
better very soon five days in the dark
was enough to strip away the necessities
of life
getting life back to normal will take
much longer
jackson prosko global news bailing in
the middle of a crisis is never a good
look and there are calls tonight for
texas senator ted cruz to resign
he flew to mexico while millions of
people in his home state were suffering
photos of senator cruz at houston
airport and on an airplane rapidly
spread on social media wednesday night
so did the outrage today cruz was seen
heading home
checking in for a flight at cancun
international airport in a statement he
didn't apologize he said our girls asked
to take a trip with friends wanting to
be a good dad i
flew down with them last night and i'm
flying back this afternoon
the u.s advises against all travel to
mexico because of covid 19.
what if the novel coronavirus is here to
stay still ahead an infectious diseases
physician
offers some hope
it is hard to see where the world will
be six months or a year from now
one question that is being debated is
whether we have to get used to the idea
that the coronavirus
is here to stay in january the journal
nature asks more than 100 immunologists
infectious disease researchers and
virologists whether they think the virus
can be eradicated 89
said no they think it's very likely or
likely to become
an endemic virus meaning it will
continue to circulate in pockets of the
global population for years to come
it is a big topic of tour of course and
dr suman chakrabarty is
an infectious diseases physician at
mississauga hospital he's here to help
walk us through this doctor
one epidemiologist in the survey said
eradicating this virus from the world is
a lot like trying to plan the
construction of a stepping stone pathway
to the moon
it's unrealistic what is your view
i agree with that you know a respiratory
virus job
is to go basically go from person to
person it can happen when you have very
little
symptoms it's very very contagious in
that sense so it's not something that
you can completely eliminate but that
said it's going to change the way it
actually is over the next several months
it becomes something that's more like a
circulating virus like we see with
influenza it tends to
cause problems in the wintertime but
it's something that's not going to be
the same type of bad pandemic spread
that we're seeing right now
well is that what it means when a
disease is endemic as opposed to a
pandemic and
how does that actually affect the
population yeah when you have an endemic
disease it's something that's there
at kind of a low level of transmission
and you might have sometimes where
there's our spikes in transmission but
it's not the same as it is right now
where we have these massive spikes that
can overwhelm hospital systems
it's more something that happens you
know seasonally and we deal with this
every year when we deal with influenza
so it's something that we live with
uh it's it's uh you can do it for years
and you have a vaccine that can keep
things even better under control
and i think that's what we expect to see
in the next several years yeah well i
want to ask you about what role
vaccines will play they'll reduce the
risk of infection of course but will
they be game changers that will
really allow economies to open up
absolutely obviously it's part of the
entire picture that we're having with
our fight against the virus but vaccines
are a huge part of that
it takes severe disease and turns it
into something that's mild or a
non-existent and with that
you can have a lot of pressure taken off
the hospitals you're saving lives you're
saving morbidity and all these types of
things are our ticket out of the
pandemic
i do expect that we might need boosters
in the future but to have another
pandemic with this same virus is very
unlikely so things will
largely get back to normal as 2021 rolls
on so if the virus does become
endemic and is going to be with us what
do we do what do our
lives look like from day to day well our
lives would look
to be honest the same it's just that in
the hospitals around the winter time
december january
uh this will be part of our respiratory
virus panel that we'll look for when
people come in with respiratory symptoms
we'll have to brace for it because there
are times where there are a lot of
patients with respiratory illness that
require ventilation or hospital support
so we look for that in the health care
system in the community we don't have to
really do all that much just like you
don't do right now
but again the general things washing
your hands and that type of thing
will still be very important you know
australia and new zealand
are attempting to have zero coved and
and they lock down right now when even
one case emerges
is it possible that that could become
the norm that some countries will
effectively eradicate it and
only people who can prove they aren't
infectious will be allowed to go there
you know i think that's possible but
unlikely because at some point they have
to open their borders
they have a very significant uh
advantage to us being geographically
isolated
and that's one of the reasons they were
able to uh do this in terms of the uh
covet zero but that said that at some
point in the future they're going to be
having cove it's not going to be at a
very high level
they can deal with it with vaccination
and any cases that come in the hospitals
will be able to deal with it
overall so it'll be back largely to the
same uh
style of life that was pretty pandemic
well that's a positive message dr suman
chakrabarti thank you so much for your
expertise
thanks so much for having me take care
news blackout what facebook's battle
with the australian government could
mean
for canada
when australians checked facebook for
news this morning they got nothing
the company is in an escalating dispute
with the government which has proposed a
law that would result in internet giants
including facebook and google
paying media outlets for content used on
their sites
and it's not the only country rethinking
the rules about getting
big tech to pay for news redmond shannon
explains
australians knew facebook might do this
but it was still a shock
from the early hours of this morning the
social media giant began
shutting down australian access to the
pages of major news sites
facebook has even emptied aussie news
pages for
all users worldwide people will just
revolt against it like honestly like
especially the younger generation
there would just be chaos the aussie
anger stuck by facebook also
initially removing non-news pages
including charities and essential
services
this is an assault on a sovereign nation
it is an assault
on people's freedom it's all happening
because australia wants
social media sites to share some of
their huge ad revenues
with news outlets broadcasters and
newspapers have seen
ad income fall since the start of the
internet era
facebook argues it actually helps by
driving traffic
to new sites if we had actually talked
to each other
we probably would be in a much better
situation than we are today in contrast
google has struck
multi-million dollar deals with some
australian news outlets
so will the minister insist that
facebook pay
what they owe in canada now that would
be solidarity with the australians
ottawa is considering a similar law to
australia's
just last week mr mr speaker i was in
conversation
with france germany australia finland
the consequences for how news is funded
could be huge
but it doesn't actually tackle the key
issue which is
that the model we've largely had for
journalism and largely for print
newspapers
is broken that advertisers don't go to
print newspapers nearly as much as they
used to
the federal government has already
pledged 600 million dollars to help some
struggling use companies redmond shannon
global news
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is saint albert botanic park
in
saint albert alberta there are beautiful
spots all over this country please email
yours to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching robin gill will be
here tomorrow and i'm back on saturday
with the new reality take care of
yourselves bye-bye